oh yeah i have a picture of somebody  no okay so you have jake um  okay  um  okay  well they're all like uh depression era  okay  [Music]  [Music]  themselves  no it's just like it makes everyone  crazy and you know what i would feel  that way if i was not because  support and defend the constitution of  the united states  of the united states against all enemies  yes  foreign and domestic foreign and  domestic that i will bear true faith  and i will bear true faith and  allegiance  that i take this obligation freely that  i take this obligation freely without  any mental reservation without any  mental reservation the purpose of  evasion and purpose of evasion and that  i will well and faithfully  thank you congratulations  there we go congratulations  accusers  you